video games peter brown hello and
welcome to the lobby game spots weekly
hangout every tuesday at 2pm pacific
right here on gamespot.com hello to all
our friends in the twitch chat as well
and hello to all our ear friends
listening in a podcast nearby how are
your ears doing peter brown they're all
right have they been squished you've
cauliflower ear because of all this
oculus rift vive stuff you've been doing
i will say the vive is digging into my
ears i could not get those straps to fit
properly gone is digging into my hip man
you love that dress
is it less comfortable we're actually
going to get to that later on let's just
jump right in is it less comfortable
than the i think swift really yeah but
let's let's talk about that one in a
little while good point because scott
butterworth's here and you have played a
game i did let's just jump right into
that you've played a game that a lot of
people want to play it's not ever a
month and it feels like it's been coming
out for yeah well it got delayed twice
so uncharted 4. it's like finally coming
out next month and i got to play it last
week how much did you get to play only
to play one mission so it was like 20 25
minutes worth of gameplay um but it
showed off sort of various aspects of
the game it was kind of a nice little
just um
portion of the game that showed off each
of the you know individual aspects
that's going to play a larger role in
the overall experience so there was some
traversal some exploration a lot of like
driving around a four by four right and
then like a nice combat section at the
end so i got a little taste of
everything the game has to offer cool so
it was that the part that they just
released the gameplay for this week with
the sort of the jeep and the mountain in
the background exactly so i got to play
that myself last week and captured some
footage so the footage that we have up
on our site currently half of it is
stuff that i captured in half of it is
from the official footage that they
released okay um it's a pretty long
demo that they released actually it's 16
minutes yeah yeah
i took a little longer because i just
kind of like explored around like a lot
of that footage kind of cuts out the
optional side areas that they just kind
of like breeze past because i guess they
want you to find them for yourself when
you play the game but yeah the game
clearly has more exploration now there's
just like little side pockets and
journal entries you can pick up and like
you know there are the same kind of
collectibles that have always existed in
the franchise but there's kind of more
like story content to discover on the
side now um i mean like the way i framed
my whole preview for for what i played
last week was how the last of us is
influenced uncharted and for me one of
the the most obvious ways is the way
that uncharted now treats sort of the
quieter moments in between combat which
have sort of always been there but were
never the focus it was sort of like like
oh yeah okay then this thing happens and
let's get on to the next set piece now
it's they really kind of like
embrace those portions and almost expand
them and they do that in a gameplay way
by allowing to explore more but they
also use those moments to like fill in
characters backstories and just have
people kind of bantering and it allows
you to connect with the characters in a
human way because it's not just like
gunfire all the time they'll be talking
about why they're there and sort of
their relationship and then just idle
chatter as well just kind of joking
around it makes you feel very like
they feel more familiar it feels like
you're more at home with these
characters so it's kind of cool the way
that they they've done that scroll back
in the chat says the chatter back and
forth and the video for this was so good
the amount of like incidental dialogue
they seem to have in this game is like
almost like i don't trust it until i see
the full game because they were just
chit chatting like there was one part in
the demo where you drove through a
waterfall and like sully gives out to
you because it's like
you said you've just got like got me you
could have given me warning before you
did that there were quite a few moments
like that including several that do not
appear anywhere in the footage that's
online which is stuff that i happen to
see during my playthrough cool so
they're yeah they're i mean they clearly
have written a great deal of dialogue
and other types of character
interactions that you know
there's a good chance you will not see
all of them because they are sort of
ambient they just occur naturally as you
play and you might not do a thing that
triggers a particular conversation um
and also i've noticed that um for
example if two characters are conversing
and i stopped the jeep and got out and
went to explore something they would
acknowledge that i was stopping and
getting out they'd be like okay i guess
you're not interested like just give
drake a hard time and then when i got
back into the jeep the conversation
would continue they'd be like so anyway
and then just pick up where the
conversation is
there's a pretty sophisticated kind of
conversation system happening in the
background that again to me feels like
it's borrowed from last of us because
there were a lot of those moments of
like joel and ellie just kind of walking
somewhere and using those you know
commuter moments as an opportunity for
storytelling um so it's interesting that
they have really kind of leaned into
that and at least in the portion that i
played did a really excellent job of
fleshing that kind of stuff out and yeah
it'll be interesting to see if they can
keep that up for the whole experience
but i mean it's it's naughty dog man if
there's a developer i have faith in to
accomplish this they're probably the
team to do it yeah it sounds like one of
those games that's perfect for those old
like sound test things and like the menu
of the game where you can cycle through
and play all the sound effects
yeah just like on a genesis car like
yeah yeah streets of rage just got one
through
uh
yeah except they used to do that when
there was like 12 sounds in the game
it's probably a bit more now what's the
yeah peter will know this like what was
the size of like the sega sound file
where like you started your genesis and
it goes sega like that apparently took
up a huge amount of space on every card
really isn't that a thing yeah that's
what i've heard that like that audio
file on its own was often as big as the
game that was on the cartridge
really yeah well i think i can't verify
it i can't verify it might be right i'm
sorry to put you on the spot like i said
no no no peter is like our resident
historian so i assume that like if
anybody knew we'll do some research for
that i'm surprised i haven't heard about
this before and chat might know
fill us in this is the i swear this is a
thing uh we should fill them in on
uncharted though more importantly i want
to ask another question about this which
is i guess like you talk about your last
of us sort of you know comparison which
is you know it's a
sort of an easy comparison to make
because that's what they just made yeah
in the most recent game and also this
was a sort of like a tonal shift from
the from what we've seen in the
uncharted series which are games where
you're basically killing loads and loads
and loads of people and one of the
things in the last of us which they
tried to like delicately balance was you
know how horrible it is that joel has to
murder and ellie has to have to murder
all these people um
which was it's like a different
balancing act like some games have done
worse than others like bioshock infinite
was one of those games it just felt like
two different games with the story and
the combat like is there an element of
that in here where like they're fleshing
out these characters and they're having
this lovely road trip and then they're
again murdering like 15 20 20 people at
a base
i mean there's there's definitely still
a disconnect as there is in many
shooters where you're you know killing
an inordinate number of people i mean i
think that was part of what allowed it
to feel kind of realistic in in the last
of us the number of enemies you were
killing was substantially lower so in
addition to going out of their way to
justify
like here's why you had like this is
you're fighting for survival like you
really like they will murder you you
have to kill them and like it really you
know enforces that idea
but also there were fewer people to kill
so it felt believable uncharted still
killing a ton of dudes like the combat
section at the end there were at least a
dozen guys that you just kind of gunned
down and then drake is immediately all
like quippy and happy again so there is
a disconnect but i mean like that that's
always been there
and i feel like that's true of a lot of
shooters
it's it's an interesting topic that's
worth exploring but i i don't know that
it's like a huge problem for uncharted
it still has the same tone it's not like
it's become a drastically more dramatic
game as a result of having been
influenced by the last of us the tone
feels very much in line with the rest of
the series it's a you know it's a pulpy
action experience there's like
explosions and like funny jokes things
like that oh they're funny are they
actually funny jokes so far yeah i
laughed a couple of times during the the
gameplay thing i watched anyway yeah
just like
uh slowly giving out about the winch
the whole way through the process and
eventually they have to use the winch
because he had to pay more to get the
car with the winch and they was like
we're never going to use it and then
eventually they use it and he's like
that's only one that's like one one time
we've used it like i didn't have a
problem with the winch i had a problem
with paying more for the winch yes i
mean there's nothing that's like laugh
out loud hilarious because it's really
not that kind of game but it's the kind
of stuff that like
makes you relate to the characters just
kind of smile and you know there's this
sense of camaraderie among them that
that you know at least it won me over at
least and in the same way that previous
entirety games have looks gorgeous too
it is a very good looking game yes uh i
don't know that it's like it's the best
looking game of all time but it's yeah
it's
the the step up from uncharted 3 which
obviously was a playstation 3 game
very noticeable this is a gorgeous game
especially relative to previous
franchise entries so i think players can
at least look forward to it being a very
good looking game if nothing else uh
these i guess bass elements bass
invasion elements at the end of it where
you there are all these you know this is
essentially an outpost with a bunch of
dudes in it and you sort of have to take
them on take them on like
hard to separate that from games that
have come out in the past couple of
years especially like last year with
metal gear solid in terms of oh i wonder
how i'll be able to tackle this was
there elements of stealth in the world
did they work well
like once you're seen is it just like
everyone knows you're there like how is
it how does it work yeah it is basically
like once you've been detected like
that's it like all hell breaks loose
there's nothing you can do about it
you're now in a fire fight but yeah
there are total metal gear vibes to the
way that combat works now it's not
drastically different from the way that
it worked in previous entries but now
there is an extra layer of stealth on
top that's it's basically optional i
mean if you want to just charge in you
can go ahead and drive your 4x4 straight
into battle and like not care
but uh there are now tools
that players can utilize to sort of plan
their attack a little more or thoroughly
or like find a way to give themselves
the upper hand so like just to give you
a quick overview there are now uh
indicators above enemies heads let you
know if they've noticed you it'll start
to fill up if you're sort of in their
sight line and once it turns yellow
they'll start searching for you actively
in a sort of assassin's creed kind of
way once they spot you then that's when
combat starts but if they're just sort
of yellow and they're kind of suspicious
you can still like hide or you can
stealth take them out before they notify
everybody else that hey drake's here
let's go kill him and stuff um so you do
have the option to take a more stealthy
approach this time um again you don't
have to but it's it's kind of cool that
they have at least equipped players who
want to play that way with the tools to
do it and how did the jeep feel actually
considering it looks like we've seen two
sort of long demos and both of them had
a lot of driving in them yeah it is
interesting that they've really
committed to the jeep but it handles
well uh again it just feels kind of like
an opportunity for them to you know
imbue the game with a little more
storytelling and just give you kind of
something else to do when you're
traversing between combat moments and it
allows for uh more free exploration i
mean they've talked a lot about how this
is the largest uncharted both in terms
of the length of the game but also in
terms of the size of the environment and
at least in my experience that has
proven true like the the hills of
madagascar that i was driving through
were definitely it was definitely a very
substantial area they refer to it as
wide linear so it is funneling you in a
particular direction
but there's a lot of space to explore
as you're heading in that direction so i
i absolutely share peter's eye roll but
it did it did prove true for me at least
that there was a lot of area that you
could potentially explore peter is now
making faces the podcast people are
missing out i love competing peter's
excellent expressions of disdain
everyone's missing out on the camera
what's your favorite wide linear game of
2015
i don't know oh it's not quantum break
one break yeah oh yeah we'll get to that
actually in a little bit uh final
thoughts i guess on scott it's coming
out may 10th on the playstation 4. yeah
it's
finally happening i guess the last thing
i'll say is that i also got a chance to
interview neil druckmann right who is
both director creator creative lead on
last of us and the creative director on
uncharted 4 and just talking to him
gives me a lot of faith in the game i
really
like his very thoughtful approach to
making games uh he very much has a
storyteller's mind and for me that's
really important i know a lot of gamers
don't really care about story they will
skip cutscenes and whatever but i really
like feeling like the the gameplay has a
purpose right i know what i'm doing and
i have an incentive or you know being
like hey flip the power switches and
restore power to the gate is not nearly
as exciting as hey this character that
you care about and are invested in is
going to die unless you do something go
do it
that to me makes the game much more
enjoyable so his approach very much
seems to cater to that type of game and
so yeah just having an opportunity to to
talk to him about all that stuff give me
give me a lot of faith in the project
and yeah just like where his head's at
so people should definitely go check out
that interview if they haven't already
it's up on the site
thank you so much scott are you laughing
about wide linear again no he likes
where his head's at and i was like on
top of his shoulders
that's just because you've been playing
virtual reality for the past week your
head has been separated from the top of
your shoulders for all i know so much it
is a funny phrase though you're you're
not wrong
uh thanks so much for coming on that's
all about it that's good it sounds like
i was kind of wondering if there might
be some like red flags waved with this
one because it's like it's it's like
true well trodden ground now for the
series but it sounds like it's it's
interesting they i mean in talking to to
the developers though i talked to other
developers besides uh neil druckmann as
well they seem fully aware that like
yeah this is the fourth installment and
we needed to like do something different
and kind of go bigger and really give
this series the send-off it deserves so
they're aware of the fact that yeah this
is we've done this before and we got to
do something different so again i think
that's kind of where the storytelling
and the exploration are coming from it
just adds another dimension to the game
that was always kind of present but was
never fully explored so yeah i mean
everything i've seen of the game gives
me faith that it will be a worthwhile
experience i'm not saying i'll guarantee
you 10 out of 10 but at this point there
were no real red flags there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be like a
total mess or anything like that so yeah
i mean i'm fingers crossed that it all
works out sweet all right let's shift
gears a little bit here gentlemen let's
stop talking to you scott for a sec yeah
we'll never talk to people peter brown
uh from games i'm trying to think of
some sort of
connective tissue between these two
franchises what do you think you're
thinking both of guns there you go both
of male protagonists third person
both have time wizards
no but there's always some weird like
you know there's always aliens or
something in uncharted games who knows
there's god knows what's in quantum
break let's have a little chash peter
brown yeah let's have a chat about
quantum break yeah uh 6 out of 10 on
gamespot.com 6 out of 10. 2 out of 5 on
giantbomb.com 2 out of 5. 8 out of 10
on ign
8.5
on polygon and game informer gym
starting as well digital spy give it a
sweet 5 out of 5.
um
yeah i want to talk about this because
i've been playing quantum break for the
past couple of weeks and when your
review was going through qa i was like
yep
yep totally i'm like talking to jeff
about it he was like i think probably a
bit more down on the combat but he was
yeah yeah otherwise it was like yep that
seems about right and then i saw and i
know like our scale isn't as we we tend
to use a lot more of it than most sites
but when i saw all the other reviews i
was like wow okay yeah i don't want to
like cast any like
any negative you know opinions towards
any of those other reviewers because
they truly like the game that much cool
but yeah i was just
it was like did i play a different game
did i did i miss something here
uh but yeah i think people are having
very different reactions to this and
it's interesting to me that
like i i had spoken to jeff a little bit
about his opinion but it was but it was
mostly like the day before publishing
the review because i was like i'm really
anxious people are gonna get really
upset with me and i just need to know
are you in line with me because if
you're not then i should be anxious but
he was like no i'm not okay i'm not
alone but then it turns out we're alone
me and him are the two that are the
outliers and we work in the same
building
and uh i don't i don't know
what people see in this game like they a
lot of people described the similar same
problems that i had with it which are
which are
like
let's get into it a little bit for
context for other people i i don't want
to just rattle off a list it deserves
more explanation um so where would you
like me to begin pick a
pick an aspect of the game and i will
tear it to bits okay let's talk about
the most the most important thing about
the game which is the movement combat
moment-to-moment gameplay in terms of
like what you're actually doing and
controlling the main character yes
movement feels like you've got
20 pound weights on each one of your
feet or maybe like you're going through
mud maybe that's more accurate it is
slow it is unresponsive it is loose
and you know you're getting into combat
scenarios where yeah you have these time
powers that help you you know move
around quickly get uh advantages on the
battlefield and stuff like that but at
the same time there are moments when
that's taken away from you
and you have to resort to using just
your basic mobility
and it just becomes so clear at that
point that something is missing
and that's something that's missing
extends to when you take cover like this
is a game that yeah maybe you don't want
to call it a cover shooter
but you're lying to yourself because
anytime you go up to anything that is
waist high you duck behind it
automatically aka you take cover
um like most of the engagements in this
game involve you taking cover or if not
running from cover to cover like it is
right absolutely a coverage right it's
imperative because the only way to
recharge your your time abilities which
allow you to do various things is to
take a break and let them you know it's
a cool down time or that kind of thing
so
you know and your health recharges as
well same thing so you just you go hide
you get some health back you get your
powers back and you keep going um but
when you can't use your powers
and you want to use your gun from cover
you don't have you don't have the
ability to blind fire yeah you have to
stand up no matter what to fire your
weapon therefore exposing yourself
i
i'm gonna pull no punches here it is
ridiculously stupid that that was a
design decision that made it into this
game i remember i remember you said it
to me and i thought oh this never came
up for me and then later that day three
times somebody flanked me and i couldn't
just shoot them crouching i had to stand
up and let eight people shoot at me
i don't even want to hear the argument
that this game isn't designed to be a
shooter because then why the hell do i
have guns and why the hell am i forced
to use them at some point and i also
that happened to me way before i got any
of the other powers which kind of
mitigate that like the ability to like
run faster yeah no but dude later in the
game there are these machines that
literally strip you of your powers right
yeah yeah it's not even that you don't
have access to new things you don't have
anything you got nothing but your guns
and the fact that you have to get shot
just to shoot somebody when you're
trying to protect yourself and i'm
totally with you on the movement and
like even the aiming everything about it
just feels like you know that kill zone
thing that's like the easiest is that
people say like kills you felt very
heavy and the aiming was it was heavy or
whatever um i like actually for whatever
reason i actually was fine with killzone
i was fine with grand theft auto 4 which
is another one that people say kills on
three was pretty good right but this one
was something about it just feels yeah
it does not feel like oh this was meant
to be a shooter first no it's it's it's
well yeah i mean i don't think it is
necessarily but that's a very strong
component of it and uh the aim assist
feature is turned on by default and i
turned it off and he's like no i need it
like
i'm ineffective without it and i don't
think it's because of me like i feel
like it's because like the game presents
you with scenarios with a certain level
of stress and threat you have to react
within a certain amount of time and this
game just doesn't really afford you the
ability to do so with any amount of
skill yeah you so at that point the auto
aim just becomes like a thing you need
and the the powers themselves although
like you can sort of guess what they are
there's like a bubble shield wheelchair
so you regenerate there's one that like
stops them in a time bubble so you can
load them full of bullets but like none
of they all seem desperate like none of
them
connect to each other or you can't
really chain them in any sort of
interesting way i so i i think jeff
described a similar thing to me but i i
kind of disagree like i found a really
good rhythm during combat um while you
can upgrade your powers and the
differences aren't incredibly noticeable
when it comes to the moment-to-moment
stuff of chaining different moves
together
being able to increase the frequency
with which you use an ability during a
charge
made a difference for me so i was able
to you know zip across the field cap a
time shield
cast a time shield you know put a bubble
out there shoot that guy on my shield
ran out zip somewhere else behind cover
and then you know just kind of like mix
those abilities together and
i found that to be pretty fun the combat
is pretty easy your powers are
they make you very op the game only goes
so far as to introduce you know big bad
guys that have a weak point in their
back yeah um which they're not that
difficult to take though they're not
that difficult to take down but they're
shocking their ai is points glow they
don't but they're bro they're yellow
bright yeah yeah okay and they have the
same uh monarch logo on absolutely
everything in this video yeah yeah
literally everything is a giant logo on
it
we're the bad guys
cool okay yeah even the security guards
have like these hoodies with m like sewn
into yeah the hell maybe we're getting
to picky here but like no we're not no
we're not that's hor that's
dude come on no that's awful
it's not it's not the real world they're
trying to present this really dramatic
situation set in the real world where
people actually have real life problems
that are a part of the greater struggle
in this fantasy
and then they have goofy henchmen it's
just like yeah just pull you right out
of the experience so the other like like
sort of the main like cons or the main
dramatic pull in this game i'm not sure
if we should talk about this necessarily
is the fact like the time is going to
end for one reason or another it's kind
of a like i i never felt worried the
time was going to end at any stage
during this game
it's just yeah i know there's like a
spoiler it's literally the first thing
that happens in the game so let's talk
about it but like even then like the
main thing you should be worried about
in this game is stripped away thrown out
the window like almost immediately yes i
at no point did i have any investment of
whatever dread was being communicated to
me on screen by the characters yeah it
felt so contrived
there was one part
actually where
the there was so much emotion out of the
character because he was about to like
leave this mission we'd done and he got
up he went up to like a valet's like key
yeah like you know where he puts all the
keys and he's like yeah
and he's like valet box every car thief
stream and he like picks one he's like
yeah
and like gets in a ferrari or whatever
and drives off and it's like dude you
just murdered a bunch of people and also
isn't time about to end like why are you
just being this like cool cat yeah no i
mean and yeah i guess ties back with the
the uncharted thing about it so the the
thing about this i want to talk about is
that like obviously people rated the
game differently right yes and i'm just
interested why because it's so broadly
different and to me this is a game that
is very like
i'm right with you where it is fine it
is the main reason i think that it comes
off as more than fine is that it's
really well presented oh yeah like it
looks great one of the best looking
games of the year and like it's got you
know
decent like voice act even though like
the scripting isn't particularly great
there's something like
you know qualitative qualitative
qualitatively
whatever
good about it it just it feels like
money's been pumped into it an effort
has been played yeah put in even if it
hasn't resulted in something great so
like even the tv show it's kind of this
plotting ridiculous mess but i kind of
love it because it's so weird like i
love it because it's
and i loved it less every time i had to
watch an episode yeah i'll say that yeah
it's less than this interesting and none
of the characters seem to have anything
to do with the main story really in any
way but
i feel like a lot of people rated it
really well because it looks nice
like it's
because it comes across as a game with a
big budget and lots of like yeah i know
i noticed behind it even if it's
actually just like a you know it's not a
well-polished turret i want to say that
it's a fine game but it's not it's not a
great game by any means no physical game
that came at 10 years ago yeah i mean i
i saw people dumping on the game jumping
on the show you know calling them
middling and then me like but oh man
i've never seen a game do something like
this before and that and that influenced
their assessment and you know if that
actually made them enjoy the experience
more that's totally fair
i
it's the same reason i can't give a game
kudos just for being in vr
you know it's
there are
doing something novel is only good when
it's put to good use
and here i don't think it was put to
good use
did you like alan wake
i didn't play ellen wig okay so i really
liked alan wake yeah because it kind of
struck this interesting narrative like
chorded me and i was like oh okay like
i'm i'm in with this guy like it's kind
of crazy what's happening and it's
cleverly written and all this and like
this feels like they tried to take
the sort of charming
you know nuanced storytelling of alan
wake and apply it to
like a mainstream audience with more csi
style television stuff and it's just
it's just like not there's so listening
there's no new one it's basically like
guess what time is in play and
weird stuff's gonna happen and you're
not really gonna know what's now or
later or the before
go have fun like but that's that's kind
of the extent of it like it's all this
this doubling back on what you thought
you knew because time travel is a thing
yeah
am i completely wrong or does the whole
time
broken thing also feel like a massive
macguffin and that like it never
actually makes any like there's no
through line like it just seems to be
like at certain points time time did
something and then it's just to serve
the narrative like i don't feel at all
like i feel like somebody's going to
take this story and break it down and be
like none of this has any consistency
like maybe i'm wrong maybe loads of
thought went into it but even now i
don't like i have no
because i haven't completed it yet i'm
near off the end but like
i feel like there's i don't have any
clue what the rules of this world are
it's just like press y here to make the
bridge go back so you can walk across it
but like why can't i do that everywhere
then why does it only happen in places
which are part of your platforming thing
why why can you only use your powers in
some sections but not others there were
times where i was in an environment
looking for a clue and it was like okay
the room is so big and i walk so slow
i'd love to zip over there oh i can't
use my powers now not because there's a
device like in combat that negates it
the game just decides yeah you don't
need those right now we want you to walk
over there and we want you to move slow
enough that you notice the other items
in the environment and it's so sad that
the game which takes
such a and i feel like it sounds like it
will be very critical but we are also
yeah and i think yeah i guess it just
feels like it's kind of a missed
opportunity is that the other thing
about this game that feels crazy old
like how can you have this many
pic like a narrative objects in a world
that are just pages and pages of text
yeah i it like oh gosh the story does
not at least for me it did not warrant
the amount of time that it required for
me to like get the finer details of the
characters and their plot arcs in the
story it was to me just a ham-fisted way
to take the characters from the show and
put their stories into the game you know
apart from any sort of social or
professional connections that they had
to the main characters like you'd find
an email from the dude that's only in
the show and it's forever long yeah and
you read one and you're like okay that
was kind of interesting oh
geez there's like 10 more in this room
i think i'm gonna move on i think i'm
gonna walk away from that yeah but then
i talked to some people who are telling
me like oh did you find this one thing
oh it was great and it's like i believe
it i wish i had found that but it got
lost in a sea of
dribble yeah i thought i also i'm a big
fan of the remedy tv show stuff they do
yeah and
stuff in this one just wasn't i found
like three of them so far i think
and yeah it's just not great either it's
kind of like oh you guys are better than
this maybe but yeah and i would really
like to talk about the distribution of
activities as i constantly refer to it
as so this game is a tv show this game
is combat this game is narrative
sequences and it is platforming yes and
it's basically all divided evenly
so the one thing in the game that it
does incredibly well is well not maybe
not incredibly well the one thing the
game does well is combat right second to
that is the size the the the
storytelling stuff that happens between
action sequences
when you're walking with the character
from one point to another and even
though you're not doing anything special
you're just walking i found that to be a
good break
to just sort of like take in some
exposition and dialogue between these
characters very well produced those
sections as well like there's a reason
why they showed basically that's all
they ever showed in previews right they
were showing it at events for years
right and that stuff is cool yeah but
then you know you expect okay i just got
through this story i'm ready for more
action and then you got to do some
platforming and it's like
oh you gotta find the dumpster to climb
onto the roof to jump over to the next
roof to climb down the ladder you know
and make time go backwards before the
building was built walk in and make time
go for it done yeah but you only have
five seconds to do it and you have to
wrestle with the horrible mobility
controls to get the thing done in time
but it's all it's also all scripted so
you can only climb certain objects yeah
right yeah even though there's something
that would make your path simpler to
complete no this game is screwed up man
like
there's one thing where you had to
rewind time to make a van yes out of a
ton
when you said that i literally thought
there's a part where yeah i wanted to
jump on the van but no i have to do this
whole thing to make there is a van that
is seven feet tall you are a freaking
time wizard you've done you've climbed
on top of things taller than that in the
game you can't just climb up on the van
you have to reverse time so it can back
up so you can jump off of a roof to get
on top of it yeah like
illogical bs i i
when a game does stuff like that it to
me it assaults my intelligence right and
it assaults my time because it's like
look
i'm not here to do this basic
[ __ ] yeah
give me some give me some like make me
feel like you understand what makes a
good game don't pat it out with things
that nobody wants to do and nobody will
believe
is like a thing that has to be handled
in that way yeah it's just it's so bad
with bs did you say insult your
intelligence or assaults you're
interested i said assault i was just
yeah that's a much more powerful phrase
yeah yeah that's good seriously it's
like a writer or something so if people
want to see the full review i'll make
our allen wig sorry quantum brain is out
today quantum week quantum mechanics
yeah uh uh quantum break is out today i
i think it's gonna be very interesting
to see what like people who buy us i'm
looking at metacritic user of user
mostly 10.
really yeah well like i know it's like
been out for like six hours well that's
xbox one owners who this is like one of
their only sort of big games that's
coming out and it does look really good
on xbox one yeah like for all the
complaint you know
version that's yeah you know the game
looks great it has some good moments
some of the stories
yeah
but like the
the mesh that holds it all together is
fractured in far too many places it's
just unreliable it's very widely linear
game
hey
listen peter the only thing i want to
know uh are there and what is the
quality of the time puns in the game oh
no oh i don't remember anything there's
lots because really there's there ought
to be
do they break the fourth wall and like
wink at the camera because i don't
remember any of that we're running out
of time they literally do that all
the time oh man but i'm not sure if they
mean it half the time there's one more
point we have to address okay
other than time point the fact that this
game is designed to provide multiple
paths for you to pursue and thus
encourage you to replay the game yeah
the things that change are so minor yeah
that again it's like an insult to like
you as a person game has the same ending
no matter what game it yeah some
characters are swapped out some yeah but
none of it none of it ties into like
your story for the most part it's just
oh it's just trite differences that mean
nothing
so they go yeah quantum break six out of
ten on gamespot.com check out the review
it's a real fair game real fast super
fair it's a super fair game uh if you've
played it yourself let us on time has
passed and you haven't just burned
through in your fanboy let us know what
you think uh in the comments below but
yeah very interesting to see see what
the the fallout will be from this one uh
mr butterworth thank you so much for
joining us yeah we're going to swap you
out uh
who's rob handler he's coming in robert
uh come on in rob let's get you in uh
we've got a bunch more we have a ton of
stuff to talk about today actually
how you doing rob
so good you doing all right
super super good how you doing
it's good to see you without your vive
googly eyes on yeah finally no i love
that segment you guys are awesome that
was so much fun i think it's cool we're
going to talk about some video games
that you rob in a hot second fallout 4
and the the doom beta as well the beat
for our friends in the uk uh but first
of all let's we peter brown we had you
on here last week to talk about the
oculus rift thank you so much for coming
in you've played a lot of
vr games and then the wife
came along and you had to play more of
that so you've played the vive now it
seems like for a good week and change
well we we only got it on wednesday well
we had like a we had a pre-production
yeah i didn't put too much time in with
that because i figured oh wait for the
final one they're identical
but i've used it a lot at previous
events so yes i am experienced and our
review went up on gamespot.com today i
believe this morning excellent cool so
let's dive into this a little bit first
of all first things first
direct comparison between the two of
them
hard to make considering
you know controllers are involved in one
and the price points all that sort of
stuff but what are you feeling at the
moment is somebody who if you just had
access to both of them which one would
you go for
if i had access to both of them right
now
um
not someone who's trying to come up with
a feature or a review or like a cold
comparison right like just a real human
decision i would choose rift really yeah
why is that far easier to set up
far easier and more comfortable to
actually use for extended periods of
time
and i felt like i was able to jump into
the store and identify games that were
interesting to me
and
unlike with vive i found
fully realized games right a lot of the
stuff in vive was
currently is like tech demo type stuff
right there's a game it's like oh selfie
tennis and you're like what's this
tennis game you literally play tennis
with yourself okay you hit the ball the
other side of the court the camera jumps
over you hit it back there's like no
menu oh do you get there's no goal no
that's fine
um
and yeah an oculus is it's a far more
elegant and refined product like it's
it's not it doesn't have the same number
of
components or capabilities of vive but
that's just right now right oculus is
releasing their touch controllers later
this year
they can do room scale vr you just need
a second sensor right and
when that happens i think people are
going to realize that that is the
product that is the more user friendly
by far
just maybe not at the box has as much
options let's let's talk about the setup
stuff first of all because have you set
it up in multiple rooms right the five i
had well do you want me to do a
comparison or just talk about vive uh
five okay
so
setting up vive when you have enough
space the maximum playroom area is 15 by
15 feet but you can do it in less than
that but let's say you have 15 by 15
feet
it's very easy uh granted you have the
ability to mount the two base stations
the things that project infrared light
that is then picked up by the headset
and the controllers um do they have to
be floating in the air somewhere do you
have to like drill them into the wall
it's recommended that they're at least
six and a half feet above the ground
although i was able to set them up
closer to like five feet at home
because i had to
um
so you have to place those you have to
like trace your your room using one of
the controllers and it determines like
okay you've got a big enough space or oh
you need to do it again
um doing it at home i could have sworn
the space i had was bigger than the
minimum recommendation which was five by
six and a half feet right
but so you trace the room and then it
takes this virtual map and it puts it in
what you traced and it says okay it fits
or it doesn't it was overlapping by hair
and it was like sorry you don't have
sufficient space to do this start over
right i had to do it like five six times
and basically lie and just move the
controller a little bit like over the
edge of my couch and it was like yeah
rock on man you did it
is this something that you have to then
repeat every time so you got parents
coming over and you got to take down the
whole thing uh do i have to like do i
have like a preset
uh mode or anything like that if you
move the base stations you will have to
do it again okay um
if you
for some reason like the software gets
disoriented you have to do it all again
because like there was one time where
the floor had suddenly jumped no matter
what i was in to like eye level so i was
like constantly looking like over the
ground right because you put the
controllers on the floor and the base
stations detect where the floor is so
you have to kind of go through some of
that if it gets messed up the intention
for these things is that they will be
set up permanently
um
valves have confidently said uh you know
we find that people make room for vr all
right which is like that's like such a
subjective thing though like who knows
right who has the room to make room for
vr let's talk about the actual headsets
themselves and i guess this is a
comparison question the oculus feels a
lot
uh
is it lighter or is it is it does it fit
snugger than the vive what's going on so
it's lighter um the mix of materials is
far better especially when it comes to
the straps they on rift they are sturdy
in just the right place so when you go
to put it on it's uh
it's stiff enough that you don't
actually have to like manhandle it too
much you just hold on to it to just kind
of control it but it slips on like a
like a stiff catcher's mask yeah vive um
has four cables coming out of the top
compared to oculus is one which kind of
comes out of the side
and
its straps are really floppy so when you
go to put it on the cables kind of like
pressure it down so you have to do this
little dance to kind of put it on which
in reality on its own terms isn't that
bad but after using riff for a week
where i got i could just slip it on like
a second it was a nuisance it definitely
felt like a newspaper did it get loose
as you were using it or anything no no
it wasn't they're not loose in that
regard they're just floppy right there's
some rigidity to to riff straps um but
what did bother me too is that and this
is subjective because of my head i i
guess because no one else has told me
this but the straps on the side are
really
wide okay so whenever i put it on it's
either digging into my ears or
overlapping them right i could not get
the headset to sit comfortably without
that happening also it doesn't come with
its own headset right uh you mean
headphones headphones yeah right no it's
got like a little plug that's dangling
and it comes with headphones that you
can plug into that
but again it's
it still feels like a prototype you know
like
rift has these built in they're easily
adjustable they're comfortable they
sound really good honestly for just
what you you know packed in over your
headphones or on your headphones it
sounds really well uh so what about the
quality of life sort of stuff that like
the ui you use trying to surface games
that that work well because the the vive
has access to like the whole steam yeah
you interface and whatnot so
is it difficult to find games that are
working for i've i kind of had assumed
in my head that most of the games that
were coming out on rift are also coming
out on vive but is that is that not the
case okay so
with vive um you work through steamvr
which is sort of a
like runs on the side of steam
and it's like the big screen stuff
almost it's like using it yeah it's
similar to that um but at the bottom of
the screen when you're in the menu you
have the option to flip from steambr
steam or your desktop okay and
i really really really appreciated all
of that
because you know you're looking at vr
games and like that's all well and good
but like at the same time like if you
actually want to you know if you're in
steam and someone catches your eye you
think about something you can go look it
up
um if you get a notification on your
desktop or you know whatever you can
actually go to your desktop and you use
the controller as sort of like a laser
pointer right point things and you click
with the trigger how can you type huh
how can you type uh it's got uh the
controller sort of opens up to the
touchpad thing so you can use those like
navigate like a split keyboard cool um
it works
the experience of going to the pc works
so well and i didn't know how much i
would appreciate it until i started
using it um there was one error i
noticed where uh in steam and have a
video section and so like you know
things like kung fury or like a
documentary on a gamer on there and i
went to go play it as though it would
pop up in like a theater mode yeah steam
said it was doing that but then i
started hearing it and i put off the
headset and was playing on the monitor
right so there's still some kinks to be
worked out
um
but yeah like you know for rift it's a
much more simple experience
it is just the the um oculus home uh ui
and you can import videos and play them
in like a theater but that's the extent
of what you can do outside of oculus
home within oculus home
so do you think there's more room for
improvement than in terms of like
because the five has access to all this
whole steam interface thing does that
seem like it works better with just your
wider pc as a tool set it does provided
that you are someone who is very
familiar with steam and you know what
it's like to be a pc gamer right like
it's it's not the sort of thing that i
could hand to
someone who doesn't play games and say
here figure this out like they're gonna
probably end up gonna menu somewhere and
not realize what they did to get there
and or or how to get out
um rift on the other hand is super
intuitive uh technically in terms of you
know resolution and all that sort of so
they're identical yeah yeah
didn't did it feel any different in
terms of i space or like when you put
them on so the the way that the optics
are shaped in vive is a little bit
different than rift rift is a a smooth
optical lens vive seems to have these um
like steps you notice these hard circles
that go around right um and i'm not
exactly sure why that is i'm sure
there's some research to support that it
helps but i will say uh images on the
edge of the optics tended to blur a
little bit and rift and this
segmentation of the the optic
i can't speak
the optics and vive uh kind of negated
that a little bit
adjusting the distance between lenses um
you have sort of a uh a manual slider in
uh
in rift and you can't you don't always
know like if you give it to somebody
else you don't know where your place was
vive has a dial that when you turn it it
actually shows you a distance like in a
ui over a headset so if it ever gets
changed you know okay my distance is
this just go right back to that which is
pretty awesome
that is useful yeah the the rift i was
adjusting that i was like i i guess yeah
he'll find somewhere that looks okay but
to know like all right let me see one
let me see two yeah
we see one
so it's weird it's like they're sort of
holistic they they are doing a lot of
the same
well but there's just like little parts
and i guess
you know
does it matter to you a lot of sort of
the the build of the unit it does it
does when it comes to it affecting
comfort right like there is a an angle
to the strap of rift that goes up and
then around right yeah because they
clearly ran into somebody like me who
can't have a strap coming straight out
because it digs into your ear there's
even a little like give so you can tilt
rift forward whereas vive to do that you
have to essentially distend the strap
with rift it's just like a quick little
tilt and it's
it feels great like it just feels like a
much more thoughtfully designed headset
but would you would you still
like how much of a because we're
comparing something like we're comparing
them by binary right it's like one or
the other but like would you still
recommend the vive to somebody if like
oculus wasn't around they couldn't get a
pre-order for it like it's still a
pretty substantially well created vr
headset yeah yeah i mean it's it's got
the unfortunate thing that it has to go
up against a product that came out last
week yeah i mean these are the two like
you know sony aside because they're in a
different market i think you know two
high-end vr headsets come on one week
you kind of have to talk about them in
that in that light but yes i mean it is
good it works really well like the 360
motion tracking stuff is is great um it
just needs more software right now to
support it and i think the headset needs
a little more attention when it comes to
design last point on this you've been
playing with virtual reality for a long
time but you've been playing it quite
extensively over the past four nights
yeah how do you feel about the sort of
long-term effectiveness of your are you
excited to go home and put the headset
on you excited to play more games like
that have you felt like you've needed
breaks from vr and you you just want to
sit down and play a goddamn 2d video
game again like what is what is your
feeling from somebody who was very
excited about virtual reality right
before i had this experience i think
rift presents a really good argument
that vr is here because you've got
developers making games that
have had a lot of thought put into them
and are you know fully fledged games
even if some of them have just simple
activities the stuff that supports them
is robust enough to keep you motivated
to keep coming back um there are some
experiences like that on vive but for
the most part it feels like it's stuck
in at like ces 2012 right like this is
vr you can do this thing and it's kind
of like a tennis racket and this is kind
of like a tennis ball you know
that that i'm not as convinced by vive
especially because it's so expensive and
it's ridiculous to set up like we didn't
even get into the nitty-gritty of the
setup but it's it's a pain in the butt
um
for me
because it's so simple to use because i
know exactly what i'm getting into when
i look at the games on the store rift is
the best argument for vr
hitting the ground running at this point
cool yeah appreciate it peter brown okay
vr headsets coming out next week oh my
god
we just got a pitch from somebody for an
android based vr headset right but it's
not one that uses a mobile phone
oh but he used it but he used his mobile
phone tech inside of it so yeah get out
of here can you call people on it can
you like just pick up the headset and
stick it off your face and go like yo ma
i'm in vr [ __ ] off you just slip your
you just slip your mother like that
do you know expensive long-distance
calls
yeah
do they even have virtual reality in
ireland yet
oh it's facetiming what a bee
she doesn't watch the show it's fine hey
mom sorry
thanks so much peter uh rob you're here
we should probably talk to you about
video games you've played sure i'm so
sorry so don't be sorry
we're all friends of the fallout
universe
yeah the the fallout the bethesda
fallout universe the wwe universe
i'm trying to think about i hate the wwe
universe it's the worst acronym thing
i've ever seen in my life yeah vincent
man jumping off things anyway fallout
you reviewed fallout 4 for game spot
last year uh you've played a bunch of it
i played a bunch yeah i've put 150 hours
into that campaign um and i you know
finished the automatron dlc yeah and
then i know you're getting it
is the survival mode yeah so this is
what they they didn't put into the game
originally it was in new vegas hardcore
mode they have a hardcore mode in
fallout 4 but it's just they called it
survival mode
but it wasn't basically it's like this
is like 2.0 survival mode yeah right
like they added more things to it yeah
but what's comment now the beta well
it's in beta now it's kind of soon is
survival mode proper which adds a
significant amount of changes to fallout
4 like not even like oh we've like made
ammo carry you know has encumbrance
again it's like
do the list what do we got so it's it's
a pretty fat list so yes uh ammo now
takes weight
mini nukes that you carry around with
like you know enough to take for granted
they're 12 pounds each right stim packs
you can't carry you know i think
many people can agree by the end of the
game you have like 300 stim packs
and you're playing on very hard i know
i've heard people tell me this you you
can spam your way out of it but yeah
those have weight now so you can only
take like you know roughly 10 around um
wow
you now factor in hunger thirst and
fatigue so you can get tired the only
way you can save the game is by sleeping
in a better mattress
and you see them everywhere which is
suspicious to me at least
and then the real kicker is there's no
fast travel and there's other things
down that they tacked on including you
know you take more damage you can deal
more damage
um and you get also things so it
food health and fatigue factor your your
ap bar now okay which is like your vats
and your sprint
if you don't manage any of those three
it takes away like rads due to health so
you eventually lose all those so if you
don't do anything you can't run anymore
in like in like less than you know 20
minutes so you have to basically keep
that in in check
and it also affects what they now
introduce is your immune system
so right i didn't talk about this in the
video i did over the weekend but um
that also means that uh
animals who are um poisonous or um
you can basically you can like break
your bones easier
you can you can get illnesses like
different types of illnesses which some
of them can only be cured if you go to a
doctor
so like you just
it's a tough life out there and
i love it i mean yeah it seems like they
could have just done the oh we're gonna
add in a bunch more you know health
fatigue water management systems in here
like we're in new vegas and like we're
in the old fallouts but it seems like
they've gone like full like the long
dark on this where if you jump off
something too high you'll break your leg
and then you have to
walk the whole way like taking our fast
travel completely is like holy [ __ ] and
there are things that i like really
agree with or agree strongly with and
some things i think that could be toned
back like fast travel is pretty pretty
brutal like not to have it at all is
real brutal and there's no like a la
carte menu where you can say oh i want
like this this is okay but like let's
turn fast travel back on sure and what i
hope to come out of this is you know
specific mods that cater to like
breaking this this whole mode
you know down to like its core but you
know you can at least like you could
confidently say like okay well what
about fast travel like a little bit you
know like in between settlements right
or with yourself yeah what's your style
yeah posts whatever um
but the but taking out fast travel to me
was really
cool in that okay now i'm looking at a
map that like i can't just warp to an
area i haven't been or like you know
close by now i'm like required to like
explore again like kind of like what the
first
third of your experience was was like
seeing all these cool new places yeah
but once you start fast traveling
between them
you're not getting any of the random
encounters you're not getting like a lot
of this breathing world that eventually
by the end of the game you just don't
you don't see anymore yeah and so like
when i played just recently i like
had to go to a different area because
the game still has like those side
quests that are like procedures
procedurally generated it's like hey
judging by your map we don't think
you've been over here so now these
things open up and as does that lane
that you've never seen before so like i
was you know 150 hours in this game i'm
like walking through an area that i've
never i've never been yeah and
that like that's also like scary though
right because then you don't superscript
necessarily want to go off the beaten
path because like in your video you had
this whole thing where it was like okay
you like woke up in the morning so you
had the most daytime because at night
time it gets like
harder or like so i'm scared i'm scared
and you're like you brought like these
weapons because you were doing this type
of mission right but then you're like oh
there's a sewer i'll just go in the
sewer because the fallout game and you
do whatever exactly then suddenly you're
like oh no i shouldn't have done this
i'm
getting like swarmed by people i'm
getting sworn by people uh i'm now
drinking
sewage because
i'm that thirsty
uh that's what the doctor ordered yeah
right
and you know that's the craziest is like
the more you the more you drink uh you
know uh water that isn't purified the
more rads you get okay well then i think
oh i'll just pop a couple of these
rataways uh guess what those make you
insanely dehydrated so next thing you
know you're just digging a grave and
it's real cool and yeah and the the
craziest thing sounds great
but the you know it's a survival i don't
know i love survival games like you know
me so this like hits home but like the
other thing which i really adored was
like okay now i can't carry as much god
damn ammo as i like you know like if
it's the one thing that like you walk
into a room in that game you're like all
right where's the ammo i'm taking all
that right i'm i'm like you know super
my abilities to get more ammo because i
know i can just flip that like no
problem and sell it yeah sell it like no
you have to pick i'm going through my
ammo like i'm taking like 100 bullets
150 bullets for each of these guns
that's all i can like afford to carry
and i get down there and i run at ammo
so this is the coolest part was like i'm
picking up a damn pipe pistol something
that like you got over like within the
you know first two hours of the damn
game like screw these pieces of [ __ ]
i'm using this thing to like to survive
like it was this wild i'm like how is
this possible the game is making you use
a crap weapon like it's it always sounds
like this is the way fallout was like
meant to be played that's the way i felt
when he told me and i gave the game a
nine i gave it a really high score but
like
man i would have given it a higher nine
just stuff
and like touching on like uh you know
the i think i think what a lot of people
agree on was like why why do i need to
build a base right oh my god why am i
building a base like i was into it i got
you you get into the idea and then
you're like this is really janky and i
don't even know like i'm just coming
back here and then they're doing more
like i'm just
and then they're like oh build another
one build another satellite why do i
want to build them why would i want to
build it
like i enjoyed it just for the sake of
it because it was like ah it's like a
fun thing to do but you're right there
was like no utility to it and so then
you realize like with this game mode
i mean it's hard to say whether like
this was like you know on the back
burner the entire time this game was
made i'm not going that far but what
becomes apparent is like okay i'm
looking at my map i got diamond city in
the middle that's a safe haven you know
sanctuary in the top
if i just made you know
two south east and southwest bases i got
my stuff covered now now i don't have to
go all the way home i can establish
those supply lines that they like try to
incentivize but like
who cares yeah i'm going back to the
same place every single time so you just
start realizing like all right here is
now a map
that i'm thinking about routes and like
waypoints and and making
that efficient and
as far as travel and um yeah yeah it
almost like makes
all that stuff make way more sense like
in the context of the wider game is
there a benefit to sleeping on a real
bed into a mattress yeah
so there's like you know if you can
imagine the world you walk into a
building there's like just a mattress or
a sleeping bag the sleeping bag would be
the lowest of them
you
you get so you get tired and you need to
sleep uh a sleeping bag will only take x
amount of that fatigue away just like in
real life
especially you want to sleep in a real
bed like i'm sick of this
um
so you have to eventually to wipe that
fatigue clean you have to stay uh or
sleep in you know like a like a nice bed
uh
and like a california king right what
kind of threat count are we talking on
the sheets over a thousand jesus yeah
it's tough it's a tough life
jeff 404 says this is how this game
should have shipped
kind of feels that way all just
i mean just bits of it that seem like
like everything as far as cooking
like you said cooking stations like
now you're like oh yeah of course water
boil it but of course now i'm making
food i'm making a sandwich because what
else does it do it eliminates my hunger
and it gives me health and it's
delicious and it's less and it's
delicious and probably less encumbrance
because you're taking all these
individual items and combining them
right and certain um you know like a
death claw steak gives you so much
health and not health but like uh i
think some type of perk you know
massive hands
uh yeah so like you compare that to stim
packs like stim packs eventually seem
like well
why not go for the twofer you're right
right like that yeah they give you so
much more like simpax almost become less
like uh less important yeah and also uh
another big one which is actually really
terrifying too like where um stimpaks
you know again like toward the end of
the game you know you got 300 of these
things you just you just like oh as
you're taking damage you're just hitting
you know matching one on the line uh
quicksave quicksave yeah right exactly
now uh i think the system packs take
like
triple amount of time
two minutes when i first did it i was
like all right no problem hit it and you
see your health like taking away the
slow it's like well i better get out of
this fight then like you're booking it
like out because i mean
the combat just slows down
significantly because
you're just scared i don't know
being scared in in this game like had
its effect i feel like in the in the
early stages and by the end of it you
got i mean you get power so early on yes
but also i mean you fight a bloody death
claw in the first 10 minutes of this
game right right yeah and also here's
another one is is uh power armor you can
take a lot more weight right like a lot
i think it's like almost double i
remember thinking like all right well no
problem i'm over encumbered i'll just
put on my power armor it's like 10 more
slots oh right so it's nothing so it's
like nothing at all like power armor
is just something that you can use as
like a defensive measure like you're not
like able to carry more stuff does that
mean your companions can't carry like
everything as well
that is diminished as well to the same
extent where like you're you're already
your inventory is cut in half they can
take about half amount of stuff too
right but now you got these robots like
i can go on forever now you got these
robots
who like from automatron automatron
which are like again like you play the
single player campaign of that and it's
like all right i'm done now what do i do
now these robots are even like more
essential because you start can like you
know you get really nitpick and gritty
we're like okay i'm gonna like pimp out
one of my robots and just have this
person carry or be able to carry and
just be like a you know walking
like a mule yeah exactly
so you can like customize your like
robots to paint that or like one of them
i um the one i was using i put on like
um
uh regenerating health field right
oh cool yeah so like when i'm out of
combat she'll like uh boost my health up
oh wow automatically so anyways sick
gosh that's pretty cool uh last point on
this i guess is actually yeah what i
want to ask you is is this some beta
it's not actually it's a free update
it's it's not out yet for everyone right
how did you opt into the beta was it
difficult no it's it's
oh as far as like how to do it yeah yeah
yeah it's it's only there's that feature
in like every game you know you got
properties and it's like the beta
section you just
you turn it on
but i will say
man
it was rough as far as crashing yeah
like crash the desktop like so often i'm
in the forums and everyone's just crying
like yeah my saves are now messed up oh
god thank god and so i finally got to
work
doing whatever it was you know like
windowed mode i don't know yeah um a
bunch of just random stuff with windows
xp compatibility modes oh i gotta run
really good oh i got to work but like
you know it's you know beta and what
about the
player level like would did you would
you start the game with this or did you
go in with like another character no i
so i went in with like a level 49 right
uh and that was still really difficult
to play this game from
a new save would be insane right just
like that first i mean i'm thinking up
until power armor like
yeah that's gonna be rough that's gonna
be rough it's yeah but it's totally like
you know if if the game for i feel like
so many people like halfway through it
just gets boring and not challenging and
you still want to retain your character
like holy [ __ ] this is the way to go
all right rob thank you so much for
coming talking about fallout 4 survival
mode looking forward to that let's shift
gears over a little bit to another
fondly remembered franchise the doom
multiplayer beta was uh was on last
weekend i think it was this weekend just
this previous weekend um i got to play
it for the first time properly you
played it back at quakecon last year was
it oh yes oh yeah what about you rob you
played some over the weekend as well i
played uh roughly like four hours cool
yeah probably about same as me yeah um
what were your initial impressions of it
i dug it i
the pacing was nice i mean it was
different like i don't know for me as
like a i like fps is like just as much
as everyone else but like i think what
i've become tired of is like just dying
immediately right yeah and there was
something about this game that like you
know having
health and armor scattered around was
like okay cool let me get like a nice
streak in because that's always what you
like really want from a shooter is like
having a streak i mean obviously skill
needs to be a factor of it but this game
kind of prolonged like the combat and i
thought that was
i mean just like you know initial
thoughts what type of you you play
you're sort of like you play a lot of
halo and call of duty and so yeah right
yeah uh we're definitely halo not much
call of duty but a lot of there's a lot
of halo in this yeah i mean some of the
like visuals in it for me i was really
i don't know down on this going into it
i hadn't played it yet but i was kind of
worried because i'd seen a lot of the
trailers i'm like are you showing a lot
of team modes here and it's looking very
space mariney and not a doomway more
like a halo way um and i did i did kind
of enjoy it but it feels very much like
it's stuck in some sort of limbo between
those two games so certain affinities
developing this uh for aid and they're
the folks who helped bungie with i think
halo 4 i guess it wasn't bungie well
they worked on halo 4 and also on call
of duty ghosts as well so they're sort
of of that ilk when it comes to this
that type of multiplayer and like
there's a lot of stuff which is straight
up
from
that that type of game which is like you
there are leveling up there are loadouts
i mean you only carry two guns you can
pick whatever two they are and whatever
sort of grenade or optional other type
of
accessory um i guess as well uh yeah the
leveling services the one armor and a
piercings like you know like
swapping your helmet out yeah and
unlocking that stuff as you level up as
well as a sort of part of it um and
although it has like you know the doom
type weapons
they don't feel like doom
but what they felt like was kind of fine
like i was enjoying this game on its own
terms but to me it doesn't really really
feel like doom all that much what did
you think yeah like i felt like it's
been months now i think this is back in
july that i played it
there was some like shades of quake in
there especially when it came to
movement and things like launch pads i
thought those were really fun and i
enjoyed that aspect of it um i played
just i think it was a single mode on a
single map over and over again you know
and it was in a controlled environment
but i had a lot of fun with it like i
really enjoyed the fact that
it feels like a game
that i haven't played in a while even
though like i can see where you guys are
coming from with the comparisons that
are similar between other games
the what it amounted to all the parts
together felt
different enough
but i don't know if i'm going to be able
to like play this long term it's going
to come down to a lot of you know how
much there is to do and whether or not
it's it's fun to play yeah i think
the mechanics feel right for me
i like the map design that i played on
but you know limited impression um i
liked the what you're talking about the
sort of momentum in it was was pretty
good the
mantling was kind of you're right it
feels way more quakey in that like you
know it feels almost like quake you know
uh what you call it the the hook mod you
know where you're like
getting up to higher positions that's
what the mantling felt a little bit more
like um all the team all the modes
they've talked about so far and all the
modes that they've shown so far and
they've shown in their trailers as well
have all been team modes which again
doesn't feel very i mean that's not very
quake-y either unless you're talking
about like team arena like that wasn't
part of the sort of base level of play
in this particular arena shooter so like
like on the this revenant stuff as well
is like super weird i actually hate the
revenant all right i think it's really
stupid like let it let people find guns
maybe like i know it doesn't it's not
really designed for that at this point
but the revenant thing is just sort of
like hey you're op you can fly you can
kill anybody in one hit have fun yeah
which is like great if you're the
revenant but if you're not it's a
horrible experience
yeah i mean like
i'm a firm believer of like
power weapons on maps like halo uh
halo has always been like that's been my
favorite thing right like everyone comes
in at the exact same playing field so
you can see that chart in the end you'd
be like that's that's me and that's the
basis of doom and quake yeah it was like
unless you were playing like 1v1 was was
map control and getting to the railgun
or getting to the bfg or getting into
the rocket launcher or whatever the hell
you wanted to do i mean to be throwing
this in right like well to be fair you
do have to find it on the map right like
it's not like you choose to be the
revenant beforehand you have to find the
pentagram you should transform into it
and it is a droppable thing which at
least is good so there is some sort of
incentive to for everyone else to kill
right
but like it changes so much more than
what a weapon would change yeah so
red and dead says can't imagine the
player base on consoles sticking around
for too long this is kind of the thing
about this where it feels to me like
they're hitting some sort of middle
ground between people who want like a
hard like i'm not sure if there's the
audience for a hardcore arena shooter
anymore like unreal tournaments doing
this thing on on the pcn alpha and i
love that and it's good fun this seems
like it's trying to take that sort of
like arena shooter vibe and then marry
it with something a bit more mainstreamy
right but like you said i'm not sure if
there's enough in this for like a lot of
people to
stay with it for very long i liked a
sample of the concept yeah but do i want
to order the full dish
i don't know dang eat that dish what do
you think rob what are your as somebody
who does like playing sort of halo call
of duty big mainstream modern shooters
online shooters what did you think of
this was this was like a novelty to it
or was it something you think you're
going to want to play more of i'll
definitely play more of it i i
personally got a nice kick out of like
the just basically picking a loadout of
like a rocket launcher yeah
yeah yeah yeah i like to change it up i
like things with it with that change it
up at least and then still have that
simplistic value like you know seeing
the reverend
was it called again revenant revenant
guy flying around
it's just like ah screw that dude like i
don't know i just want to go around
corners with a shotgun uh not have to
worry about like going for these these
and we need to talk about like those um
what do you call those mods those hacks
the hacks or whatever i yeah didn't get
like a full like grasp on like when and
how those operate yeah but like it was
just another like thing i felt like
thrown in was like wait what so yeah it
doesn't mean people can see me now or
something like that whenever they spawn
or like now there's a guy who wants to
like have my head
it's like dude it's a game like
yeah it doesn't take too personally man
they're like almost like titanfall burn
cards but instead of like benefiting you
they sort of yeah like all it did was
like it put countdown timers on the on
the spawns or you could do one which was
like the person who killed you you
basically could see through [ __ ]
walls like you had a wall hack for that
one person which kind of seems unfair
it's like unfair they kill me fair
square why am i now able to just like
run up behind them basically and murder
them because you can if you get them
like two rocket shots and you're dead
right like two you know shotgun shots
are dead i don't know maybe they'll
tinker a little bit because of the
debate of feedback but i did enjoy it i
did i was i was definitely playing it
until like they closed that beta like
wait what's going on yeah oh damn
love to have kept playing but um yeah
i'm definitely on the fence as well i
mean it's definitely
well said like it's in a little bit of a
limbo like on the fence like
what type of game is this like i do see
that that pull towards like progression
i i really get nowadays you know what i
mean like
there's got like i don't know for me at
least like i do kind of want to see some
like incentive to like all right well i
want to look different like
i want a little bit of a pull toward
like even the differences were like the
main difference since you know the
colors colors which you had all at the
start basically yeah the other ones was
like you were basically
changing [ __ ] cod pieces like you
couldn't no one's going to ever notice
that like i
will well for slayer you would right
just um
um just one-on-one what do you call it
just just death match right right if
you're if you look exactly the same
opposed to like you know red and blue or
whatever but i don't even sure if
they're doing normal oh they better
death match in this because all the
modes that they've shown because they
have one trailer where they literally
list all the modes they're all team
based
so damn they have this like god that
would be shocked that'd be shocking it
wasn't deathmatch
every game that's like if a street
fighter came out it didn't have our kids
all right thank you so much mike my
hearty was about to say
he's coming in a second
uh rob handlery uh peter brown thank you
as ever for your time yeah we're waiting
for mike um for rob handlers
tick-tock tick-tock is he here his mr
there he is thank you goodbye everyone
have a great day bye rob
thank you so much
mike you put a shirt on
before
just walking around half naked it's
great you look great
how are you doing my friend good how are
you i'm doing wonderful
i'm doing i'm having a great day the
show's running on long which is good we
had a lot to talk about
it's good fun
enjoying it yeah have people stop asking
you to be kevin van oorjet
no not really
kevin van orde kevin van ordos uh
was tweeting about that too yeah he was
yeah um
he says he would have given dark souls
the same score as you so hopefully
hopefully people
can back the [ __ ] off and stop being
weird about it yeah let's talk about
dark souls 3 cool so our review for dark
souls 3 your review for dark souls 3
went up uh was it a couple days ago yes
yesterday midnight yesterday yeah
yesterday early morning cool edition on
gamespot.com you've been playing a bunch
of us in the office for the past while
uh we've had you on to talk about it in
vague terms yeah i mean mary and erica
were playing it a bunch as well so it's
been chat around the office for a little
while now sure eight out of ten so i
guess we got a bunch of questions for
you from from the gamespot audience but
what are your sort of main takeaways
from dark soul where does this fit in
terms of the quality of previous games
where does it fit in terms of a game a
dark souls game coming in 2016 when
everyone kind of knows what the format
is now sure uh it's actually really good
this is probably a question but it's
probably a good entry point for someone
despite the fact that it's the third
game and the what i think is going to be
a trilogy what i'm pretty sure is going
to be uh it's a great game i was you
know it was it was bordering on being a
nine for me but the more i played it and
got into the late game the more it kind
of lost its momentum for me and its
creativity that the rest of the game
displayed so well
and i love dark souls i love demon souls
bloodborne uh it just
those there are certain games like dark
souls 1 and bloodborne do such a good
job of pushing you through the end game
and kind of making your progress up to
that point worth it and there's still
very much worth it in dark souls 3 but
it didn't really have that kind of
climax and then really like engaging
late game hours that i've come to expect
from the series uh something you were
highlighting was something i was talking
to eric about last week as well which
was that there's a decent amount of
repetition when it comes to bosses
in terms of their like move sets at
least well yeah each i mean
yeah i think i said redundant bosses
because
they're all kind of repetitive in a way
like when you start fighting them enough
times i think the most one boss took me
was
eight tries it's a guy named pontiff
sullivan if i'm pronouncing that
correctly but
yeah they're pronounced sullivan yeah i
wasn't gonna say it
no yeah
something i try to like lend a little
medieval flare to all these yeah fair
enough yeah
and uh no but some there were about
three or four bosses later in the game
one of which is one of the main bosses
you're hunting down one of the lords of
cinder as they call it
and i was playing them and i realized
i'm using the same exact strategy as i
used against this boss the second boss
of the game or the fourth boss of the
game or the first boss of the game uh
and they're all still really they're
well-designed boss fights but
really heavy deja vu kicked in while i
was fighting them and i was like oh i'm
just staying between this one's legs
which you know you play earlier dark
souls you do that with a lot of the
bigger bosses and a lot of the bosses
who kind of thrive on the uh those
sweeping attacks like the 360 so that to
kind of keep you off their side but you
know i
you start playing these bosses and you
would like to see some more um
creative liberty later on the game but
it doesn't it feels like they kind of
i mean i'm not evaluating their
intentions but it feels like it kind of
the game feels fatigued after a while
because
you know i'm repeating something i've
done earlier despite the fact that my
character's gotten better i've gotten
better i've learned a lot since i fought
that boss four hours in as opposed to 20
where i am now and that kind of i didn't
feel cheated because it was still it's
still really fun and there's still a
huge reward in killing that boss but
it's still at that point i i wanted the
game to reflect the progress i had made
yeah because that's the alluring thing
of dark souls tell me that's because
the whole point of the series are the
thing that people love about it so much
is that it respects the player sure and
like teaches them like requires them
requires quite a lot of them in terms of
skills so if you're saying that the end
of the game sort of flounders now
respect and yeah that's got to be a
bummer sure except for like the last two
bosses are really great um one's pretty
you know without spoiling too much the
last boss doesn't do anything completely
new it's definitely a fun boss and it
was it's well worth it it definitely
makes sense to have that as a last boss
unless you you know barring any optional
bosses of which there are a bunch uh but
the last like
boss in the main story is also it's
pretty creative in terms of how you
fight it so yeah there are there are
some really bright points later in the
game but not enough to really kind of
push me through as much as like
bloodborne or dark souls 1 or demon
souls did
real killer 789 says the formative for
the game hasn't changed a lot i kind of
want to talk to both you about this you
know the original dark soul orgas you
could say demon souls are dark souls and
to a certain extent bloodborne these
were games that you know were we're
doing something new or at least doing
something new for a new audience and
obviously that's something that us as
reviewers really like a lot when or you
know we play a lot of games when
something does something new i think
we've rated very highly and so does the
audience like people like when they're
surprised in a new way um obviously dark
souls did that in in the past uh i'll
ask you first of all peter do you think
that makes a big difference for a
reviewer when now we're talking about
you know it's the third dark souls game
but we've had demon souls in the past
and bloodborne they exist within this
sort of group of games
that sort of trick doesn't ring as
true you know it's not as interesting as
you know this far down the line surely
right
it can't contribute as much to a
wonderful you know game review because
we kind of know that trick is it's
coming for the most part when we're
reviewing a game that's further down the
line in a series we find someone to
review it who has experience and and
that's because we want them to
have a discussion that is well informed
um
not to necessarily prop the game up
against somebody who's going to
recognize
what hasn't changed
um that said whether or not that's
important is down to the individual
who's writing the review yeah
i mean i feel like this has come to my
table when it comes to like fifa and f1
yeah in that there are like games that
do the same thing every year right and
they do it well and maybe they don't do
enough and maybe they do do enough and
it's kind of difficult to parse i mean
my biggest criticism of assassin's creed
syndicate is that like oh yeah i get
that somebody would really love this
game but for me
i feel burnt out on this series so
that's the reason i would personally
rate it so low yeah and that's and
subjectivity is very important yeah yeah
so what do you think about this does are
we you happy enough just to play another
duck so i know and i i want to say as
well it is weird that we're talking
about this when we gave the game a
[ __ ] 8 out of 10 because that's a
really good review but there is this
weird sort of backlash or you know
sort of an idea on the internet though
it's not a minor it's just aren't school
grades yeah yeah yeah
50 or 60 is not failing yeah for sure so
what do you think about that in terms of
you playing it subjectively did this
game do enough for you as a dark souls
song would you even willing to play
another dark souls 2
uh well that's the thing i think pete
and i had the discussion yesterday
afternoon or something and he said yeah
reading a review i got like halfway
through it and i was thinking to myself
well this could just be any dark souls
game you're reviewing right now right
but then you get toward the end of my
review and that was my point um dark
souls 3 despite a lot of the things that
they've been kind of touting is new it
doesn't do that much new the main new
things i saw was in its structure and
how you go throughout its world and how
that kind of factors in i mean there
there's the the new fp bar which uh
dictates it's your map it's essentially
a mana pool for your weapon arts and
that was kind of an afterthought for me
um every once in a while i would use
them and they are helpful but it didn't
really factor into how i was fighting
bloodborne has seeped into this a little
bit i think
i described this as if as if dark souls
1 and bloodborne had a baby it would be
dark souls 3.
yeah that'd be a grotesque looking baby
bloodborne indeed
and um sorry it doesn't it doesn't do
the same thing for me that dark souls 1
did uh i think i still think dark souls
won like
even looking back now at dark souls 1 i
think is still the best in the series
despite the fact like even removing any
you know novelty from it like now that
we're on three it might just be that i'm
tired of the series i'm really not i
mean bloodborne was is
you know it's not the same series but it
does so many great new things and it uh
i'm more excited for a bloodborne too
now than after playing dark souls oh
really yeah but dark souls is one i mean
i can't i actually just started a new
game the other day because it came with
like the retail copy of dark souls 3.
and it still does so many things better
than two and three um i think three is
like my third favorite i think if i had
to rank them it'd be like dark souls
bloodborne demon souls actually which is
still a great game uh three and then two
not that i dislike two but yeah i think
in hindsight
it's weird looking back at one because
usually like you said on the third of a
trilogy they have to kind of try to keep
the momentum going however they can i
still think one holds up better than any
of them
yeah it's it's a great game and you know
three a big thing with reviewing sequels
how is it different i don't think three
is largely that different than the other
ones yeah and uh that's not that doesn't
make it a bad game it's still it's a
great game i'm i'd be very surprised if
we got to the end of 2016 it's not in my
top ten cool um but yeah i just didn't i
didn't i don't think it did anything
really special like the other ones did
no worries i got a bunch of questions
here about um a hero at the top and a
bunch of other people asking general
questions about frame rates platform to
play on all that sort of stuff yeah how
does it look across all the platforms
which one sort of
runs the best i mean as you can imagine
it run it looks better on like a nice pc
um it looks good on all of them uh the
frame rate issues there were
some and they it dipped pretty low but
it was never in a time when i actually
it affected the game the first spot i
noticed is when after you're approaching
this boss and you kind of they're strong
hints that you're about to go up against
a boss so i tried to backtrack to the
previous bonfire and the game does this
thing where it just a bunch of these
skelet bones rise up and create like
something like 30 skeletons and then the
frame rate dropped but i wasn't really
near them you could just tell the game
was chugging right so that didn't really
affect it too much there's definitely i
think it runs a little better on pc from
what i've seen um they did say there was
a day one patch or patch incoming that
supposedly is going to fix them and i
want to jump back in yeah i don't think
it's going to really affect my review
but the frame rate dips never really
affected me i know timur in the uk is
playing and i don't think he noticing
anything severe although i am seeing
other reviewers that
had problems with it uh and
yeah that's tough because i don't know
it didn't really affect me personally
which i'm grateful for but if the game
isn't running smoothly that sucks but
yeah i'd say pc is
pc looks great runs well um it's not
locked at 30 frames like the consoles
are but the console still ran smoothly
for me cool awesome uh so it feels like
we've had this in the office forever is
it actually out today or is there next
week no it's out yeah tuesday tuesday
12th next week all right awesome yeah
bunch of games coming out between
now and e3 it seems like yes in that big
window of time there are many
it's like two months i thought you're
gonna say this month i was like there's
not much no i'm not that's just looking
at me before i came on and it's
bad well it's great it's really great
but in terms of like trying to play all
of them it's yeah yeah
bonkers time all right well we had a
packed show full of video games to talk
about today uh so we better wrap this
one up thank you so much to everyone
who's been watching and listening really
really appreciate it uh we are uh this
will be up of course as ever on itunes
if you want to listen to it i mean
you're if you're watching this you
probably don't also want to listen to it
but hey i'm just throwing it out there
if you want to do it the options there
uh thank you so much to everyone in the
back for helping with today's show as
ever mary kish eric tay our man dan
mahork thank you so much and we will be
back next week
we will be right back for the lobby next
week you can tune into dead
oh yeah plug in it perfect yeah dead air
it's the horror podcast myself and mary
kish or hosting it uh i believe pete's
coming on this week cool you're talking
about some
horror games are faring in vr when's
that going up it'll be on thursday
afternoon this thursday two days now yes
perfect awesome we also have a vive live
stream planned for friday and i also
have a podcast oh really yeah peter
brown experience
wait a minute hold on rewind quick
did you also know on friday afternoons
speaking of air speaking of air we have
another likely titled podcast about a
very different genre
pete what is it alexa ray korea and i
will continue uh with episode three of
airship our podcast that's focused on
final fantasy but japanese rpgs and
games in general sweet and uh it's a
great show tune in tune in
for the release date of final fantasy
15.
sorry you can't just say final fantasy
that's just like that's a soft love
jesus christ that should be fun so
that's on friday that's going up on
friday thursday friday yes you think all
right thursday friday yeah i like it we
also have no those no
we got a bunch of stuff in the side
bunch of reviews up as well so if you
want something to read go check out
gamespot.com right now videogames.com
as for live streams we'll be back on
friday thank you so much everyone for
watching and listening as ever and if
you don't watch the friday show be back
2 p.m pacific right here on the lobby
adios
you